What happens if we introduce Dr.
Gears’ pocket watch to the Clockworks?
Four clockwork pocket watches, belonging
to Dr. Gears, were prepared for testing.
First, a gold-plated watch was placed in
914 on the setting “Fine.” It produced a
small clockwork bird that, when its tail was
pressed, emitted the sound of a robin’s call.
Next, another identical watch was
run through the machine on “Fine.”
This time, it produced a small toy
train engine, powered by clockwork.
The next watch run through
on “Fine” emerged as a tiny,
fully functional grandfather clock
set to Eastern Standard Time.
The final watch produced a little
metal sculpture of a piano.
Though each watch was placed
in 914 on the same setting,
and was made from the same materials,
they all produced a different result.
The only common thread was the
metal and the presence of clockwork.